il n'y a pas d'âge pour apprendre la
formule est bien connu mais rares sont
les retraités à se lancer
jean-louis lasnier un mini montant de 64
ans n'a lui pas hésité il s'est inscrit
à 1 cap2 cuisine par correspondance mais
non j'ai dans un environnement familial
on a toujours cuisiné progressivement
c'est un centre d'intérêt qui c'est qui
s'est développée en moins chambre de
façon plus ou moins je dirais pas sur
nos armes mais à mon insu et contre la
traque a raison je me suis dit là voilà
après une carrière passée dans la
gestion des systèmes d'information
jean-louis ne rechigne pas à rouvrir des
livres de cours
même si ce n'est pas son activité
préférée je travaille de façon en
fonction du temps que j'ai et puis de
l'envi que j'aime être aussi certaines
fois on il est sûr que quand je rentre
des deux journées au je suis en stage le
soir enfin leur milieu d'après midi plus
tôt j'ai absolument aucune envie de me
replonger dans la partie plus littéraire
car si jean louis a décidé de s'engager
dans ce c ap c'est avant tout pour
perfectionner sa pratique de la cuisine
et la faire partager à sa famille et ses
amis on n'est pas sur le palais midi on
est sûr préparation de rien de
maquereaux et dont on ne fait pas
forcément pour mehdi je prépare mes
actes j'ai toujours une
un penchant pour la cuisine on va dire
goûtu la cuisine avec des aromates avec
des huiles d'olive avec de l'ail la
cuisine du sud donc je fait bénéficier
les zones de mes acquis et c'est pour
moi un bond de joie parce que pendant
raison que je garde ça pour moi
côté pratique jean louis a décroché un
stage chez le restaurateur eric leautey
dans son restaurant de thoiry ce matin
là nous le retrouvons en pleine
préparation des jus de viande que je
vaux va servir à agrémenter un certain
nombre de plaintes le chef veut avoir la
carte aujourd'hui ça va on ne sait pas
trop mal sorti une première depuis leur
union d'accord il s'est fait un choix
qui était de tenter de rentrer ici c'est
eric leautey à paris et à ma grande
surprise il va accepter tout s'est tu
pour le chef l'âge de ses employés n'a
pas d'importance
seule la motivation compte mélanger les
générations peut même être fédérateur
pour sa brigade
il m'a dit je veux pas seulement ses ap
/ traité vrai mais où est le problème
pas au contraire et même quand on est à
la retraite on peut se former encore et
c'est surtout quand on est passionné
quoi et donc sa sas c'est un bel exemple
aussi pour les autres le ca paix prendra
fin dans quelques semaines pour
jean-louis il sera s'il est admis en
juin prochain
le retraité passionné de gastronomie
pense déjà à son prochain défi et cela
pourrait bien être une formation en
charcuterie